[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
sur tv 78 radio sensations la semaine
dernière 10 mai oblige nous avions des
invités de gauche avec les socialistes
dès d élever des france a soumises des
générations et aujourd'hui on va parler
plutôt de la droite
pourquoi parce qu'il ya une d'abord une
étude de la fondation fondapol qui ne
fondation de sciences politiques qui
montrent que les idées de droite sont en
train de grimper
non seulement en france mais aussi en
angleterre mais aussi en allemagne mais
aussi en italie seulement en angleterre
il ya un parti conservateur avec boss
johnson en allemagne lcd ou avec un
galet merkel ou son successeur
en italie il ya onze de centre droit
avec mario draghi et puis en france il
ya des républicains la partie plutôt
sans tête et sans idée et c'est pas tout
à fait lui même figure enfin s'entête
110 et vous me direz si vous êtes
d'accord avec ça on va parler donc la
situation de la droite et peut-être
d'une des personnes qui peut incarner
cette droite c'est valérie pécresse et
le point qui titre et si c'était elle et
si c'était elle la candidate à la
présidence de la république on parlera
aussi du retour du voile dans le débat
public et puis du pass sanitaire est ce
que vous êtes pour ou contre
et pour parler de tous ces sujets and
charlène bezina bonjour vous êtes maître
de conférences à l'université de rouen
anne perdriau bonjour on serait très
sain vous êtes conseiller régional ile
de france est proche de valérie pécresse
vincent couronne bonjour donc on joue
avec le fondateur des studios lignières
vous êtes enseignant et journaliste et
jean charles lajoie ni bonjour vous êtes
éditeur toujours un bonjour à tous
toujours échappé à la toujours content
et fier de l'être
et heureusement il ya un courageux qui
est sur le plateau c'est laurent mazaury
s'ouvre jour bonjour patrice que vous
êtes maire a demandé l'encours de
vice-présidence de saint quentin en
yvelines et président de tv 78 grand
plaisir voilà j'ai tout dis donc au bas
on va commencer par ceux ce premier
sujet c'est vrai que la droite est elle
cette étude d'at fondapol est tout à
fait passionnante
la droite est de retour et comme titre
et le point propos de valérie pécresse
et si c'était elle c'est vrai que
jusqu'à présent on parlait beaucoup de
xavier bertand comme comme candidat de
la droite on se parle aujourd'hui de
valérie pécresse est vrai que les
elysées des élections régionales
approchent et c'est vrai qu'elle a dans
cette interview elle développe un
programme qui dépasse évidemment la
région l'eia intéressant c'est que les
deux candidats favoris de la droite ne
font pas partie de l air oui c'est un
fait c'est un fait effectivement avéré
patrie avait raison après je ne suis pas
certain que ce soit rendre service avait
dérivé crès de la présenter dans le
point est d'ailleurs merci il ya un
point d'interrogation sont donc voilà
l'a présentée comme la présidente
elle est aujourd'hui candidate à la
région ile de france elle entend à ma
connaissance exercer pleinement ce
mandat c'est un petit peu moins vrai
pour xavier bertrand qui lui a
clairement dit qu'il serait candidat à
la présidentielle mais je pense que
madame pécresse est vraiment directement
engagée dans sa candidature à la région
avant cette extrapolation évidemment
journalistique évident à bord d'ailleurs
elle dit aussi que si elle n'est jamais
elle n'était pas élue à la présidence de
la région arrêterait elle aussi la vie
politique à une paire brio qui
connaissez bien côtoyer valérie pécresse
évidemment c'est vrai qu'elle a un
programme qui pour la région évidemment
son premier son premier challenge c'est
d'être réélu à la présidence de la
région mais c'est vrai que quand on lit
cette interview il ya un programme qui
dépasse
le la campagne régionale
alors vous savez on a l'habitude de dire
que l'île de france c'est une petite
france parce que les gens pensent que
l'île de france ça n'est que l'urbanité
jallet dean alors que 80%
d'ile-de-france et en fait des surfaces
agricoles rural etc
on dit souvent qu'il de france c'est une
petite france alors ça c'est l'anecdote
concernant valérie pécresse c'est vrai
que bon d'abord c'est c'est une femme
c'est une femme et je regardais un
sondage de 2020 qu'avait fait harris et
qui disait que aujourd'hui 70 % des
français seraient prêts et sont prêts à
lire une femme
donc ça c'est un point à un autre point
je pense bon elle a été ministre et elle
a un sens assez fort du régalien est
pour moi le régalien est une brique
incontournable c'est ce qui a fait
défaut d'ailleurs à emmanuel macron je
pense que pour quoi on a l'impression
aujourd'hui d'être un peu sur un bateau
ivre
c'est parce que emmanuel macron n'avait
pas cette connaissance des élus locaux
du territoire français du maillage du
territoire français n'avaient pas
forcément la culture des du régalien
l'armée la police etc je pense que c'est
un indispensable pour prendre ce type de
fonction et puis qu'est-ce qu'on dit en
général que pour être pour avoir une
fonction de chef d'état en fait il faut
il faut avoir fait ses preuves
je pense qu'elle a été ministre que
qu'elle a un bilan au niveau de la
région qui est assez étonnant
en cinq ans pour ne citer qu'un exemple
elle est arrivée à venir à bout de ce
fameux déménagement et je peux vous dire
qu'il faut être une sacrée chef pour
être arrivé à avoir fait des ménages
la région ile de france 16 16 sites en
un donc rationaliser donc elle à elle un
bilan elle a fait deux milliards
d'économies cumulées sur cinq ans donc
elle a ses preuves elle a une vraie
vision politique
et puis enfin c'est une grosse bosseuse
c'est à dire qu'en politique
malheureusement je trouve que les
politiques ne travaille pas assez c'est
à dire qu'une fois qu'ils sont élus
c'est comme un aboutissement
c'est un peu comme le mariage quoi on
est mariés up non c'est le départ c'est
le départ et elle elle n'a pas perdu une
seconde de son mandat elle n'a pas cessé
de bosser
voilà et je pense que ford je disais oui
voilà fort de toutes ces qualités
je pense que voilà elle elle pourrait
tout à fait légitime
par la suite si les franciliens déjà lui
font confiance à hunter président alors
c'est vrai que voilà les les français
pourraient en effet porter une femme à
la présence des deux républiques encore
que dans une élection qui se joue
parfois un ou deux pour cent il ya
peut-être un ou deux pour cent des gens
qui disent qu'ils disent encore je me
trompe peut-être pas pour une femme en
face et ce serait très intéressant de
savoir parce que les déclarations qui
font dans les sondages sont pas
forcément les l'ale le comportement réel
qu'ils ont le problème de cette droite
justement c'est qu'il ya déjà xavier
bertrand c'est que peut-être valérie
pécresse peut-être encore des dates du
duel air que certains vont aller vers
des primaires d'autres pas c'est à dire
qu'il ya une division quand même il ya
une tête a trouvé en effet c'est vrai
que de toute façon dans notre histoire
constitutionnelle de la vème république
on a des candidats généralement qui sont
désignés assez tardivement les familles
politiques ont un peu l'habitude de
deneux s'entrechoquaient avec des
candidatures multiples je pense par
exemple à l'élection de 74 avec jacques
chaban delmas avec ces questions aussi
qui font que souvent la presse fait
émerger un candidat idéal
et ça n'est jamais lui qui au final soit
remporte l'élection soit remporte même
l'investiture de son parti donc je crois
que la vème république nous a appris à
nous méfier du candidat favori qui
généralement ne ne connaît pas un destin
heureux on pourrait citer aussi michel
rocard ensuite bon et valérie pécresse
j'ai peur qu'elles puissent faire en
effet mal à dieu j'ai peur qu'elles
puissent faire figure de candidat un
petit peu trop
c'est un peu de ton à mon avis pour pour
la déclarer notamment parce que ça se
déclare par voie de presse et elle peut
jouer un peu cette figure de 2 du modèle
mais qui finalement n'aboutit jamais
donc c'est c'est la grande question est
ce que finalement ça n'est pas un peu
tôt on peut penser à xavier bertrand
aussi pour se lancer dans une campagne
alors qu'il n'ya pas encore d'unités
alors qu'il n'ya pas encore
véritablement de position partisanes
alors il ya aussi autre chose que cela
veut dire c'est la république en marche
quand elle a commencé en 2017
elle a fait exploser le système partisan
de la vème république on a plus de
bipolarité ps républicain et donc le ps
a exposé le premier et les républicains
se sont un peu on va dire structuré en
une opposition avec notamment
l'opposition sénatoriale
on a eu le sentiment que c'était un
parti qui existait encore un petit peu
or là moi j'ai le sentiment qu'il est en
train un petit peu de faire preuve de
son éclatement également et donc ça
confirmerait que la reine a fait
exploser le système partisan de la vème
république et il faut dire aussi autre
chose pour l'élection présidentielle ça
n'est pas certain que l'éthique est
partisane de droite de gauche du milieu
soit vraiment pertinente parce que les
français choisissent avant tout un
destin est une personnalité à laquelle
ils vont s'attacher est donc une femme
un homme je suis pas sûr non plus que ce
soit vraiment là la bonne question c'est
est-ce que les français vont vont
finalement considéré que le changement
viendra de cette personne là parce que
la vraie caractéristique française de
l'élection et de toute notre histoire
c'est que
nous votons en réaction à ce que nous
avons vécu c'était pareil pour les
constitutions a toujours fait des
constitutions inverse à la précédente
et c'est pareil pour les élections donc
il faut que quelqu'un soit capable
d'incarner ce changement un changement
même qui apparaissent radical pour que
les français utilisent la solution tient
on n'a pas encore essayé ça et c'est
celui là à mon avis qui emportera le
haut du panier
c'est pour ça vous avez raison de venir
de rappeler ça c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
la difficulté des des sortants à se
faire réélire parce qu'on a toujours en
recherche toujours un changement dans
les élections présidentielles laurent
mazaury vous faites partie de l'ue dit
kerry alliés howell r c'est vrai il ya
une notion d'âge qui est paru hier dans
le parisien sondage ipsos qui qui est
terrible pour pour le pour le pour le
monde les républicains parce que au fond
les 65% des sympathisants disent que
bord il pourrait très bien aller aussi
bien vers le rn que vers vers macron
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de structure
idéologique à plus de dia panne d'idées
tellement de travail d'idées depuis
depuis quatre ans au fond du puits de la
lecture de de mâcon dans ce dans ce
mouvement
j'irai dans le même sens que ce que anne
charlène viennent nous exposer c'est un
petit peu la conclusion de ce délitement
mais je pense que ce qu'il manque avant
tout c'est le leader ou vous
charismatique ce soit un homme ou une
femme c'est pas jacob
je leur montre et je respecte son
travail mais c'est pas le leader qaïda
qui peuvent à redon on a déjà eu ce
débat je pense que dans une élection
présidentielle mais dans toute élection
est parti en dans celle là la partie
marketing ce n'est pas forcément
péjoratif du candidat effectivement son
histoire son engagement sa façon de
s'adresser aux médias s'adressait à la
façon dont on parle aujourd'hui manière
moderne aux médias c'est essentiel si on
veut effectivement ensuite porter les
idées de son parti
moi je pense que le parti des
républicains ne manque pas d'idées lui
dit non plus d'ailleurs dans tous les
partis a des idées je pense
qu'effectivement les idées du parti des
républicains correspond aujourd'hui à ce
que les français attendent qu'il faut
c'est quelqu'un évidemment pour pouvoir
les incarner mais les incarner ce n'est
pas simplement incarner les idées s'est
déportée et c'est en cela qu'on a besoin
de figures particulièrement efficace et
qui parle à l'ensemble de la population
un deuxième point patrice sur lequel je
voulais revenir quand on disait tout à
l'heure c'est peut-être un risque au
contraire une chance sur une femme je
pense que ce qui est plus problématique
promenant dans l'élection présidentielle
c'est peut-être souvent
ries contre la province et j'ai toujours
noté qu'il est très compliqué d'être un
candidat issu de paris ou lille 2e série
alors c'est un cas particulier j'allais
dire parce que alors là on parlait de
rupture on était vraiment rupture avec
ce qu'on avait connu avant
on est bien dans ce côté c'est est ce
que c'était une rupture par rapport à
chirac est tout à fait que si wright et
maire de paris mais chirac était maire
de paris mais pour tous mais l'idée des
gorilles
voilà et donc je crois que c'est pour ça
aussi que la personnalité des avis
berton il faut vraiment la regarder de
près parce que son côté je suis parti
dans le nord j'ai fait dans le nord une
région qui aujourd'hui apparaît comme
d'abord avoir fait une sorte de
consensus de un petit peu l'ensemble des
partis d'ailleurs de cette exprimé en
rupture et en opposition avec le
rassemblement national alors valérie
pécresse a fait la même chose mais elle
a peut-être ce défaut elle a
effectivement la plus belles régions de
france alain parcours à mon sens qui
comme on disait tout à l'heure et
extraordinaire elle a montré que c'est
une femme bien entendu la première
région d'europe
là dessus il ya aucun doute sur la
qualité ça après il faut effectivement
faire admettre au reste de la france que
je suis bien une candidate pour
l'ensemble des français et donc il faut
être capable et c'est l'homme il ya un
peu un piège avec ces régionales il faut
à la fois porter le programme régional
et gagner ces régionales est ensuite
capable de s'en extraire si on veut être
candidat à la présidence c'est un vrai
challenge
en tout cas vous avez raison de dire par
exemple xavier bertrand joue sur joue
presque le côté je viens de province et
bien sûr su proche des français en gros
c'est ça va un peu ensemble vincent
couronne justement dans le sondage dont
je parlais de ipsos qui est parue dans
le parisien notamment et sur france info
justement il ya ce reproche au fond
c'était de montrer que le parti
républicain n'a pas choisi puisqu'il est
écartelé entre eux ceux qui sont partis
ces macro comme comme le maire comme
quelques autres
et puis ceux comme eric ciotti qui
disent bon il ya nous la différence de
cette différence d'autres le rn et nous
c'est que nous on a l'habitude de
gouverner c est ce qu un moment il va
pas y avoir besoin d'une clarification à
droite avec une partie qui va partir
vers le renne l'autre vert vers la
république en marche vers autre chose
d'ouvert le centrisme et ont tous et ce
qui provoquerait un éclatement justement
du mouvement et l'air et de la droite
cet éclatement dû
mouvement et l'air on le voit déjà
effectivement à l'oeuvre comme disait à
charlène bezina tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que depuis quatre ans où on
vraiment que la république en marche
arrive à faire éclater au grand jour en
tout cas les divisions au sein des
républicains on l'a bien vu dans la
région paca par exemple mais la
clarification et viendra probablement
après les régionales c'est à dire que
les régionales ça va permettre à chacun
de mettre des essais et puis ensuite de
marquer des points et de voir de voir où
on penche la balance de quel côté de
quel candidat et c'est donc de ce point
de vue là il ya probablement une
clarification qui va avoir lieu mais
elle aura lieu à mon avis après les
régionales c'est pas les programmes pour
les régionales qui nous permettront d'y
voir plus clair
ensuite il ya une question qui me paraît
centrale c'est le positionnement des
républicains vis-à-vis du rassemblement
national
si ce sondage a montré cette porosité
entre les républicains et puis d'un côté
et le racing nationale et de l'ocs la
république en marche
c'est bien que healy a effectivement un
souci de programmatique côté les
républicains une clarification qui n'a
pas été faite sur des questions comme
par exemple des questions identitaires
des questions d'immigration les
questions de sécurité etc
et quand on voit que xavier bertrand par
exemple lance sa campagne pour les
régionales en disant que son souci
principal
ça va être la sécurité que en
ile-de-france valérie pécresse et s'y
essaye aussi de mettre l'accent sur ce
sujet là mais aussi sur les questions
environnementales
à la question que la question
sécuritaire et bien on voit que il ya
une sorte le plein de flottement
actuellement qui fait que cette porosité
avec leur armée nationale est peut-être
un peu facilité
j'ai rajeuni justement il ya ces types
du dos il fonda paul qui montre par
exemple les gens qui se revendiquent de
droite il avait 33 % en 2010 738%
aujourd'hui c'est à dire 5 % en cinq ans
ce qui est quand même
de plus ce qui est quand même assez
considérable que cette idée de droite
sont majoritaires et donc on est dans
une situation comme ça qui est il des
droits ton gros majorité on va revenir
parce que c'est l'immigration c'est
l'islam c'est c'est la sécurité est au
fond personne finalement à droite qui se
détache pour incarner ses idées
plusieurs choses quelqu'un de droite on
a quelqu'un qui est parfait c'est
emmanuel macron qui est un président
président de droite claire et nette ya
aucun problème et c'est pour ça que ya
pas deux c'était très difficile pour les
républicains de trouver quelque chose
parce que effectivement on a vu et loire
philippe on a vu le maire on voit
darmana on voit des tas de gens de
droite qui avait des idées à droite et
qu'on trouve tout à fait respectable
respectable quand il était à droite qui
ont rejoint le président macro et voilà
donc ça fonctionne plutôt bien alors je
ne suis pas un fanatique de tout ce qui
est fait par macron et son gouvernement
notamment sur de sécurité d'islamisme et
de laïcité il ya beaucoup de boulot
c'est probablement ça qui fait que le
front national est sur une pente hyper
agréable va gravir la pente de façon
assez facile après on revenir juste à
valérie pécresse et elle paraît
absolument parfaite comme présidente de
région
bon j'espère simplement c'est un peu de
l'anecdote mais qu'elle ad'autres fait
valoir que d'avoir réussi un
déménagement comme comme argument parce
que quand on voit à michel barnier qui
réussit le break trith et valérie que
sert la liste
bon c'était une petite pique mais voilà
la foulée sinon après moi ça m'énerve un
peu qu'on nous disait c'est une femme
mais je m'en fous que ce soit c'est
quelqu'un de passionnant cagire
d'intéressant ce soit un homme ou une
femme tous rapports te le dire je veux
pas voter pour quelqu'un parce que c'est
une femme contre parce que ce serait une
femme
ça a l'air d'être une très très bonne
présidente de région elle a pour
l'instant un bilan qui paraît excellent
et encore des choses à faire après la
véritable question c'est est ce que une
bonne présidente de région peut être une
bonne présidente de la république voilà
est ce que peut être que son son poste
le idéal est celui là et que peut-être
après ce qui me choque aussi dans le
fond ce qui me choque
ce qui me déçoit un petit peu c'est dans
l'interview donnée au magazine le point
elle dit clairement qu en aucun cas ne
pourrai premier ministre de d'emmanuel
macron c'est un peu dommage parce que
l'or en même temps qu'elle me dit
maintenant que tu devrais le poste après
les élections mais il ya comme un peu
dommage tout type d'aidé sud se
démarquer on a l'impression que c'est
presque un problème de personne et que
le problème des idées moi j'aimerais
vraiment un jour un débat entre madame
pécresse et et monsieur mâcon pour voir
les différences d'idées fondamental pour
l'instant je n'en vois pas et c'est tout
problème de la droite c'est qu'il n'a
pas alors qu'après vous êtes tous là en
train de dire oui serré il ya des gens
de droite qui - au front national
mais bon là peu importe je veux dire
c'est pas très grave il ya quand même
beaucoup plus de gens de droite qui sont
pour mâcon ou encore pour pour barnier
pour pécresse ou pour xavier bertrand
que de gens droite pour le front
national
et après j'en termine juste là dessus
vous avez l'air tous et tonnerre dont
les idées de droite progresse mais
mitterrand l'a dit le premier tout le
monde l'a dit la france est résolument à
droite
alors après c'est comme chaque grande
élection présidentielle ça se joue à la
marge et sur la personnalité des gens
mais voilà moi je ne suis pas du tout
étonnée que les idées de droite
progresser même pas qu'elle progresse et
qu'enfin on réalise après une chape de
plomb pendant des années en disant que
de toute façon il n'est de bon ton que
d'être de gauche et de est d'être dans
le politiquement correct dans le
mainstream et c est que la ba voila on
réalise que effectivement les idées de
droite et ce sont les idées que je veux
partager un peu par beaucoup de gens et
que voilà après c'est ce qui est
important c'est que c'est pas seulement
la france mais aussi l'allemagne c'est
aussi l'angleterre c'est aussi l'italie
sans les mêmes progression et ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que jusqu'à
présent c'était plutôt se disait plutôt
c'est plutôt les personnes âgées qui
votent à droite
or la plus grosse progression elle se
fait c'est laisser les plus jeunes et là
le pourcentage de plus jeunes fans moins
30 ans en gros et de plus de 65 ans qui
vote à droite est identique qui est
quand même très nouveau sans parler
évidemment dur assemblée nationale qui
est le parti des jeunes et etde et des
ouvriers aujourd'hui mais une perdrix
pardon oui oui je crois qu'il ya quelque
chose qui est très intéressant en
comparant ces élections régionales aux
précédentes
c'est notamment la question du front
républicain parce qu'il faut pas ouvrir
aussi bien pour la région xavier
bertrand que pour la région paca il n'y
avait eu ce ce champ lexical qu'on avait
retrouvé pour l'élection présidentielle
de 2002 de faire front contre le
rassemblement national justement en
prétendant que donc ce parti n'étant pas
républicain un front gauche droite
gauche milieu milieu droite devaient
s'opposer à ce parti et je note quand
même que dans le discours politique
c'est ce mot là qui n'apparaît quasiment
plus qui n'apparaît pas en tout cas dans
l'actualité
ce qui fait qu'au fond lorsqu'on a en
paca par exemple une ligue droite aux
centristes pour soi-disant en tout cas
faire front contre le rn et bien ça
n'apparaît plus dans les idées du temps
et c'est ça qui est assez intéressant
c'est qu'en fait on a un glissement en
faveur peut-être de la fameuse
dédiabolisation du fn qui fait que le lr
a encore moins de fenêtres puisque
c'était un peu la seule chose qui reste
est à la droite c'est que c'était la
droite qui n'était pas la droite de
l'extrême et c'est elle qui avait
bénéficié de trop front républicain lors
des dernières régionales donc si on a
plus ce front anti rns qu'il reste
encore un party les républicains
c'est ça la question qui s'était
finalement déjà posées aux régionales de
2014 donc je trouvais que le parallèle
méritait vraiment de
voilà d'être mis en lumière comprendre
son positionnement et vous avez raison
de souligner ce point notre gré les
études montrent que justement ce plafond
de verre est en train peut-être de se
briser et par exemple la bourgeoisie qui
jusqu'à présent ne votez pas rm commence
à être attirés par le rennais pourrait
considérer sénat et l'assemblée
nationale comme je parle populaire un
peu vulgaire un père brio je voudrais
qu'on revienne sur ce que disait jean
charles lajoie nice tenir au fond il n'y
a pas de différence entre autres
pécresse et et et makro alors justement
vous voulez réagir un petit peu par
rapport à quelques quelques remarques
déjà sur l aire effectivement elle est
je pense que alors valérie pécresse a
quitté l air parce que il y avait une
espèce d'asphyxié toujours deux d'entre
eux soit d' asphyxie
au lieu d'aller rechercher des talents à
l'extérieur au lieu d'être clair sur
cette fameuse porosité avec le
rassemblement national et c'est pour ça
que valérie pécresse a quitté l air
justement pour s'affranchir de ces deux
choses là c'est à dire oxygène dont sens
simplement ce que les français
recherchent et et une position très
claire vis-à-vis du rassemblement
national
elle n'a cessé de le dire après pour ce
que disait jean charles justement
concernant emmanuel macron pourquoi elle
a été très clair parce que tout
simplement elle elle n'a pas le même
projet en fait elle n'a pas le même
projet si elle n'était pas clair on
dirait oui oui elle essaie de ménager la
chèvre et le chou là elle a été
extrêmement clair elle est très claire
sur le rassemblement national
elle est très clair sur le fait qu'il y
aura pas d'alliance ni au premier ni au
second tour parce qu' elle n'est pas
encore candidate 1 pour les
présidentielles pour l'instant elle
vient d'être déclarée candidate pour les
régionales donc voilà
et donc je pense qu'au contraire elle à
elle a une position claire elle a une
vraie vision et je parlais tout à
l'heure du régalien
parce qu'en fait c'est quelqu'un qui a
osé à droite personne n'ose parler du
lien supposé factuels pour entre
immigration entre terrorisme et
immigration elle a osé le dire justement
pour j'allais dire ne pas laisser
l'exclusivité de la sécurité et de ce
sujet qui est qui est extrêmement
prioritaires pour les français
en fait elle est également très clair là
dessus et là dessus elle ne partage pas
du tout l'idée du régalien 20
qu'emmanuel ma cour et je pense que
c'est ça qu'il est qu'il est qui les
divisent basque après sur la vision que
j'allais dire libéral de l'économie elle
et elle partage pas mal d'idées là
dessus des points communs voilà il ya
des points communs et puis après je
pense qu'aussi elle est très forte sur
le social c'est à dire les tous les
sujets sociaux qui concernent
directement les français quand elle
s'intéresse à la précarité quand elle
s'intéresse aux femmes dans la rue quand
elle s'intéresse au harcèlement scolaire
accéder à toutes ces petites choses ça
peut vous sembler des choses secondaires
mais qui sont essentiels pour le bien
vivre le quotidien des français voilà et
enfin un truc important aussi un élément
important aussi c'est que elle elle
s'est vraiment positionné à la région en
disant il n'y a pas de sujet de droite
et de sujets de gauche
voilà la liste l'environnement c'est un
sujet de droite autant que de gauche le
l'un des membres social c'est un sujet
de droite autant que de gauche
les lensois grognant ça c'est important
non c'est du bon sens du bon sens
ouais on oublie un peu le sens vous avez
raison de rappeler les fromageries
monsieur lajoie nivaldo dire que la
transat rice dans 35
il est un peu centriste justement est ce
que disait on perd brio c'est vrai que
valérie pécresse a fait le rapprochement
entre l'immigration et le terrorisme et
c'est vrai qu'elle a aussi une phrase
qui est peut-être importante qui est
bien dans l'air du temps de ce retour
visa blanc de la droite et on a perdu
nous avons perdu la fierté française
j'aimerais que ce sentiment là très fort
dans la population on a fait récemment
un sondage oubliez le l'organisme en
question qui dit effectivement que le
sentiment de déclin de la france je
crois frappe 7 français sur 10 on est
tous conscients enfin on a l'impression
n'est pas de faire un vaccin jusqu'à
présent ça leur fille ça y est se
rattraper
même si c'est un français qui était à la
tête de modern art mais néanmoins
effectivement on a tout ce sentiment là
alors un déroule d'ailleurs de nos élus
et et de nous mêmes en tant qu'élu c'est
de redonner cette certes et française
c'est de ne pas l'abandonner non plus
aux extrêmes
parce que effectivement on a eu tendance
très souvent et c'est pour ça
effectivement de la candide et de
candidature de valérie pécresse on
retrouve cette prise en compte de cette
notion du régalien dondon par là
impérial l'instant c'est important de
redonner confiance aux français en la
france est important de rappeler que non
quand on est français on n'est pas dans
une logique d'échec on est aux comptes
ans d'une logique que beaucoup de pays
nous envient et donc le rôle
le rôle du politique ceci dès des
perspectives je pense qu'en cela
effectivement la candidature de valérie
pécresse epr avant la candidature qui
donne le plus de perspectives le plus
d'envié qui montrent que le possible
existe encore et que bien au contraire
la france demeure effectivement un
acteur majeur pas forcément la
sénatoriale c'est évidemment important
mais surtout pour chacun des citoyens
c'est-à-dire l'unicité des chances la
capacité à tous de pouvoir réussir sa
vie en france est le deuxième point ce
qu'elle devrait revenir aussi patrice
vous avez raison de le dire il ne faut
pas abandonner on a enfoncé on l'a dit
mille fois ses portes ouvertes là mais
il ne faut pas abandonner le régalien au
rassemblement national il faut pas
abandonner la sécurité au rassemblement
national il faut pas abandonner aura 102
nationale et c'est ce qu'elle a fait
effectivement des liens etc sont
évidents alors il n'y a pas que ça mais
quand même entre le terrorisme
effectivement et une partie
certes ténus d'immigration mais qui de
fait si l'immigration étaient plus
contrôlés probablement ce terroriste
serait moins prégnant en france je pense
qu'il faut avoir le courage d'assumer
son identité politique forte du respect
de la république et cette valeur là et
là dessus je vais rejoindre ce qui a été
dit ces valeurs-là d'une république
forte j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de dire
sur ce plateau c'est pas une valeur de
droite ou de gauche c'est une valeur
fondamentalement républicaine on n'a pas
de raison d'abandonner au rassemblement
national la défense de notre démocratie
elle est éminemment de droite du centre
mais elle est aussi d'une gauche modérée
oui c'est c'est ce que dit valérie
pécresse et finalement ça ne regardons
pas la réalité en face au fait monter le
legs someone is est exactement ce qui
s'est passé ce qui est un peu la réponse
à ceux qui disaient bcl la gueule
l'original est toujours plus fort que la
commission quand les idées au fond des
eaux internationales ça fait monter
l'euro symbole national
il ya les deux thèses qui se voit enfin
sauf que non le front national papa dont
le front social a pris ses idées elles
étaient déjà passés tellement 16 avant
que le rassemblement national n'existe
et que jean marie le pen ce que je le
rappelle quand même que c'est ça à
l'origine de la fin de la guerre
d'algérie en face une forme de
règlements de comptes personnels ce qui
s'était passé pour créer un parti toutes
pièces dont on va d'ailleurs dans
l'actualité très récente que c'est
pratiquement une pme familiales
puisqu'on vient de découvrir à travers
ce qui s'est quant à lui d'un journal du
dimanche en l'occurrence hier qui
semblerait que ya une forme de
financement individuel familial qu'on a
retrouvé d'ailleurs rappelez-vous dans
la présidentielle dernière également à
la france a soumise avec un espèce de
cartel associative qui récupérer les
fonds publics pourrait se réunir et les
uns les autres
on voit bien les limites on verra jamais
ça aux républicains on verra jamais
salut d y est voilà et donc on voit bien
ce que le front national c'est autre
chose qu'un parti politique sortu
politique et on verra d'ailleurs une
influence de la sphère des financements
européens sur sur la candidature de
marine le pen
vincent couronne justement ce que ce que
disait laurent mazaury
voilà une élection présidentielle il
faut faire un peu rêver est ce que
justement on n'est pas dans une époque
où les jeunes rêvent plus et ça pose un
problème peut-être d'adhésion est ce que
on va aller d'anduze élection
présidentielle dans laquelle va
pouvaient pas voter pour quelqu'un mais
contre oula vieux débat je n'ai pas si
en plus de ça la période de la crise
sanitaire est propice à l'imagination et
à l'imagination peut-être nos rêves
peut-être un peu moins mais en tout cas
moi je pense qu'il ya une question
intéressante par rapport à la rave
justement c'est ce que beaucoup de
candidats aujourd'hui nous font ce sur
quoi ils nous font rêver
c'est la question des valeurs on en
parlait à l'instant c'est à dire que ils
sont tous à dire que il faut améliorer
la transmission des valeurs que nos
valeurs se perdent etc
mais en réalité quand il dit cela en
fait électoralement c'est ça fonctionne
pourquoi parce que chacun y met ce qu'il
veut dans ces valeurs-là de quelles
valeurs
est ce qu'on parle est donc en réalité
je pense que chacun peut s'imaginer
qu'elle est la propre c'est sa
république où les valeurs qu'il a qu'il
a envie que le politiques défendent à
partir où le politique lui ne prend pas
vraiment position c'est assez c'est
assez facile
moi je suis comment dire à la base une
formation de juriste donc si je prends
les valeurs endroit qu est ce que c est
celle qu'on retrouve dans la déclaration
des droits de l'homme du citoyen c'est
celle qu'on retrouve dans la convention
européenne des droits de l'homme
en préambule du traité sur l'union
européenne et démocratie c'est la
protection sociale mais aussi la liberté
entreprendre c'est la liberté d'opinion
la le droit à la vie privée etc
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui en réalité ces
valeurs qui sont censés nous faire rêver
éventuellement et est donc dont les
candidats aujourd'hui nous disent que
elles sont en perte de vitesse
elles sont malmenés et qu'il faut les
renforcer eh bien ceux des valeurs très
souvent en réalité elles ont été
malmenées par ces mêmes candidats veut
dire quand le parti socialiste était au
pouvoir avec françois hollande il a
porté atteinte gravement à la protection
de la vie privée avait en mettant en
place d'un système surveillance que
emmanuel maquet
continuez renforce encore la protection
sociale la liberté d'opinion la
neutralité religieuse etc tous ces
éléments là y compris nicolas sarkozy et
les promesses du rassemblement national
tout en fait quand on parle de
protection des valeurs en réalité on
sait pas ce qu'on met dedans
d'une part et d'autre part c'est le
premier problème et d'autre part très
souvent en réalité ce sont les
politiques eux mêmes en fait qui y
portent atteinte à ce tableau assez bien
là donc nous faire rire en avenir de la
france glorieux quoi que ce soit en fait
c'est je trouve ça un petit peu un petit
peu creux et g chacun mais un petit peu
ce qu'ils veulent dans oui mais voilà
les gens contre on vit aussi d'être
fiers de leur pays et la voie d'avoir
deux d'avoir quelqu'un peut-être qu il
les incarne enfin c'est un peu ça aussi
l'élection présidentielle se joue pas
que sur la rationalité
je crois que c'est tout à fait juste et
anne perdrions le disais tout à l'heure
c'est blanc bonnet bonnet blanc
économiquement entre valérie pécresse et
emmanuel macron mais en revanche je
pense que le mal eric pécresse
sûrement une carte à jouer sur la fierté
d'être français est à l'évidence le
président macron n'est pas quelqu'un qui
est passionné par la france par l'esprit
français
je pense que les français se
contrefoutent de savoir qu'on soit
capable ou pas sur un vaccin on arrivera
bien en ferrain c'est pas grave mais
c'est cette politique de la culpabilité
permanente de la repentance de l'a22 des
excuses à tout bout de champ sur tout ce
qui a pu se passer etc
c'est un désaveu de ce qu'est de ce qui
fait la spa ne président mâcon 10 kg a
pas de culture française critiquent les
françaises et c'est de ça dont les
français ont besoin de quelqu'un qui
dise on est français ou peut être fier
de lui en est on peut être fier de
l'être
la france est un beau pays un pays
magnifique il ya déjà des gens tiennent
la france d'épée il ya des présidents
qui aiment la france
visiblement le président macron il est
peut-être plus plus il a une vision
vraiment différent on le sent pas animé
d'une passion pour le peuple ou pour
l'âme française et je pense que c'est
très important et qu'effectivement
valérie pécresse semble être beaucoup
plus tatillonne là dessus et et le jeu
dit asian au sens le plus sympathique du
terme
elles sont intéressées par sa 7e cette
arme française qui existent et se fasse
et français qui n'est pas acheter
systématiquement et il faut arrêtez moi
j'aimerais à la con n'est pas un
président qui passe son temps à
s'agenouiller pour s'excuser de tout ce
qui a pu être fait et c'est mais qui au
contraire de temps en temps dit voilà on
a fait ça s'était très bien on va faire
ça c'est encore mieux et c est là depuis
depuis cinq ans c'est enfin depuis trois
ans et demi a annoncé c'est un peu
oublié et pense qu'effectivement des
gens comme valérie pécresse
personnalités parlement d'autres
peut-être aussi barnier dont on n'a pas
parlé mais voilà qui peut-être au siège
peut avoir un rôle à jouer peut-être à
côté pas les lectrices je ne sais pas
mais en tout cas voilà et puis dernière
chose pense qu'il devrait arrêter si la
droite veut s'en sortir
en tout cas les républicains et tous les
et tous les gens qui tournent autour
uniquement de critiquer le front
national ce n'est pas en critiquant un
parti qui est sûr c'est extrême qu'on
arrive à fédérer des gens père moi je me
contrefous de 2,2 ce que pense le front
national ce n'est ce ne sont pas mes
idées je ne vois là mais je voudrais que
les républicains arrête de me dire oui
le front national ceci le francia c'est
le principal agent électoral du front
national sans peur d'être des élus
républicains
c'est comme ça pardon mais ce qu'on
reproche parfois aux républicains c'est
pas tellement de critiquer c'est
partager débat d'idées quand vous et 90
et eric ciotti je vois pas tellement la
critique des républicains quand il n'ya
pas de différence entre nous sauf qu'on
en a on a plus d'expérience du
gouvernement c'est pas une critique très
très vague du rassemblement national
on n'est pas forcé de tomber dans la
caricature citant surtout un peinture
mais jean-charles c'est un petit peu là
jean charest s'est un peu toi qui
caricature aussi un peu emmanuel macron
quand tu dis que ils n'aiment pas la
france ou qu'il a déclaré qu' il
n'aimait pas la culture française pour
que ce soit cela dit la culture
française n'existe pas il avait dit
s'alarmer
culture française n'existe pas je peux
pas laisser dire une chose pareille se
passe une phrase sortie de son contexte
évidemment alors je dire on ne peut pas
imaginer que quelqu'un qui même si on
n'aime pas et mayenne macron
politiquement qui calme assez cultivé et
quand même une très très bonne
connaissance de l'histoire française la
littérature française de dire ce genre
de choses sans contextualisations il ya
je pense qu'il ya un an j'ai assez
important à c'est assez grave a délivré
comme ça des brevets de francité aux
candidats ou en politique qu'il
représente c'est complètement c'est
complètement ridicule
est ce que est ce que quand elle est
plus français qu'un autre ou plus a
peut-être français qu'un autre parce
qu'il défend mieux la france connaîtra
nationaliste en tant pis si dans les
travers nationaliste que je trouve
extrêmement dangereux aussi il faut
faire une déclaration d'amour à la
france tous les matins quand on se lève
pour prouver qu'on est à sa place
ah pardon mais moi je trouve ça
extrêmement dangereux non mais non mille
fois non juste vincent emmanuel macron a
quand même dit qu'il voulait
déconstruire l'histoire de france donc
c'est assez est là ça on n'a pas besoin
de contexte pour comprendre cette
l'intensité de cette phase là quand même
des construire l'histoire de france
oui mais ça me parait il a des souvenirs
ça ne veut pas dire la détruit a pas que
j'ai encore une prestation moi je ne
vais pas je ne sais pas de quoi il parle
et j'ai pas envisager l'américain mais
jeu mais voilà mais je laisse ça veut
pas dire détruire ce que fait manuel
macro moi je regardais fait ce qu'il
fait pardon sur la guerre d'algérie ce
qui fait par exemple même s'il a fait
sur vichy etc
c'est pas c'est pas une destruction
l'histoire de france et une
compréhension notre histoire pour qu'on
puisse a regardé en france moi quand je
regarde le royaume uni par exemple
aujourd'hui qu'un gros problème
d'identité qu'à une énorme d'ostalgie
sur sa période impériale si vous avez
remis aujourd'hui il ya des drapeaux
britannique
partout il ya une fébrilité extrêmement
importante par rapport à leur propre
histoire qu'ils ont du mal à regarder en
face moi je suis assez content qu en
france on soit en mesure de regarder
notre histoire en france avec ses
avantages ses travers et consoles ont
mis capable de faire la synthèse et il
ça fait que et ben on évite des
décisions comme le bras
10 tout comme des ddd positions
nationalistes qui sont forcément
mortifère moi n'y a peut être que
j'aimerais ajouter c'est que ce qui me
frappe dans ce dont on est en train de
discuter depuis tout à l'heure c'est
qu'on a parlé rêve va leur amour de la
france qui est à mon sens son sang sont
sont des éléments qui partout
républicain est partout démocrate
méritent d'être partagées dans le monde
entier dont je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'on ait discuté programme en fait
depuis tout à l'heure et ça me semble
tout à fait frappant du débat politique
tel qu'il existe depuis la république en
marche
on a détruit les idéologies et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je pense
qu'on n'a pas mesuré à partir de cette
élection 2017 c'est quand on joue on sur
tous les terrains justement parce en
même temps et pas parce que c'est aussi
un petit peu là la famille du centrisme
de pouvoir toucher à tout eh bien on a
déconstruit l'idée que la gauche serait
social que la droite serait plus
capitaliste et donc du coup je crois
qu'au fond en france on ne rêve plus on
ne pense plus par rapport aux partis
politiques est là à partir de ce moment
là je pense qu'il ya en effet un grand
danger parce que les français se
tournent vers les associations vers les
think tanks surtout vers les médias et
vers la presse et surtout mes réseaux
sociaux malheureusement ce qu'ils font
aujourd'hui on ne pense plus que par
affiliation à un groupe social que par
rapport à des identités culturelles avec
du coup ce sentiment de devoir
revendiquer d'être moi d'être français
ou de faire partie d'un tel groupuscule
et on touche aujourd'hui à un désert au
niveau des idées donc moi je crois que
si le party les républicains ou même le
parti ps ou n'importe quel parti
souhaitait se placer dans l'opposition à
ce qui se fait à l'heure actuelle il
faudrait trouver une idéologie de
l'opposition ce que le sénat a quand
même essayé un petit peu de deux tailles
et on va dire petit à petit avec une
opposition systématique opposition sans
pour autant développer une idéologie à
part entière alors avec mes valeurs
le côté républicain il ya quand même eu
des choses qui ont été travaillés par ce
sénat et l'air donc je crois que
l'essentiel demain pour le parti qui
devra et pour le candidat qui devra se
positionner comme étant un opposant
à emmanuel macron qui se représenterait
c'est de trouver une idéologie
d'opposition c'est de trouver de
nouvelles idées
un positionnement qui soit différente et
ça je crois que c'est cruellement ce qui
manque à la france en ce moment c'est
possible et en plus il ya une chose dont
on est sûr peut-être c'est que pardon
non hier jeudi il ya peut-être une chose
d'autres auditions on parle de la droite
c'est que la gauche quand même et etde
en péril et qu'elle sera probablement
pas au deuxième tour des présidentielles
même si c'est un peu tôt au prêt pour
faire des prévisions je suis pas sûr que
ce soit d'une tristesse total à sept
poubelles
surtout si la gauche c'est la france a
su liste des écologistes pour voir le
mal qu'ils font dans les villes qu'ils
ont gagné aux dernières élections
municipales
alors c'est l'élu qui par les militants
on va passer au deuxième thème de cette
émission bas c'est le retour du voile
[Musique]
alors la fère s'est passé on en a parlé
à montpellier des candidats paul pour
l'élection des élections départementales
avec l hérault md avec une femme voilée
réaction de bardella duration nationale
commence et c'est impossible d'avoir une
femme voilée qui se présentent à des
élections qu'est ce que fait l air m
guérini est secrétaire général d'ugt de
la république en marche dit oui en effet
ça n'est pas dans nos valeurs après il
ya des députés des élus et les robes qui
comptait ce qu'ils aient après tout
c'est la france telle qu'elle est
peut-être un peu juridique d'abord
vincent couronne avec vous d'abord
est-ce que c'est légal ou illégal d'être
voilées sur une affiche
et est-ce que enlever ce voile se serait
enfin dire qu'on peut avoir une femme
voilée c'est de la discrimination
le son le micro micro
oui pardon très rapidement patrice on
peut tout à fait avoir un voile une
croix ou non qui passe sur une affiche
électorale simplement parce que quand on
est candidat à une élection
on n'est pas soumis aux règles de la
neutralité du service public on n'est
pas un agent du service public c'est le
cas de ceux qui vont tenir les bureaux
de vote ne s'est pas le cas de ceux qui
se présentent aux élections
donc ils ont le droit de montrer leur
signe religieux c'est tout à fait
possible et le conseil d'état l'avait
déjà jugée en 2010 par rapport à une
élection il affiche de campagne du
nouveau parti camping du nouveau parti
anticapitaliste pardon en région paca
et si jamais un parti politique comme
lrm par exemple décide de retirer son
investiture un candidat qui montrerait
des signes religieux
sur une affiche est bien là aussi il a
le droit de le faire a priori parce que
on n'est pas dans le cadre d'une
discrimination au travail
le parti politique n'est pas l'employeur
du candidat et donc il peut tout à fait
retirer l'investiture à des candidats
qui montre des signes religieux
si c'est la ligne du parti sauf si sauf
si c'est une discrimination comment dire
une sur votre forme dans par exemple
racisme et c'est donc là pour le coup on
tente sur le coup de la loi pénale
mais a priori pas de problème donc on
peut être voilées sur les affiches et le
demander de retirer l'investiture n'est
pas une discrimination voilà comment les
choses sont claires
après il ya le débat c'est vrai que le
port du voile c'est c'est celle montrée
l'appartenance à une communauté une
religion et en même temps c'est la
france d'aujourd'hui que comment comment
par exemple laurent non mais oui alors
je pense que c'est propre à chaque parti
politique de définir sa ligne politique
dont on est dans le cadre là d'une
réaction liée à la ville politique je
mettrais de côté le fait que
effectivement monsieur guérini a répondu
autre acte ii au pardon aux tweets de ce
bar dès la renaissance était plate était
subtil pour vous à droite et ça c'est
bon c'est un sujet j'ai à dire c'est
connexes avec une réaction parfois les
réseaux tout le tweet oblige à répondre
mais non là c'est une problématique de
ligne politique la ligne politique
effectivement d'aller ruelle puisque
c'est ce qu'ils veulent porter c'est une
ligne politique forte de laïcité tout
cas ils essaient de revenir vers ce qui
n'a pas été fait c'était notre débat
précédent prenant par la main de mâcon
dans la première partie du quinquennat
il est donc logique en tain de ligne
politique qu'il réagisse face à quelque
chose qui a dû passer sous
les radar de la détection
centralisatrice de les vrais monstres
dans le conte alors l'affiché très
réussie indifférent minutes vous on
comprend bien le concept etc mais
évidemment quand on est un parti qui
apparaît aujourd'hui comme portant une
loi contre le séparatisme tout signe
religieux ostentatoire je suis pas ce
mot de passe le terrain de la légalité
le terrain du marketing et l'image une
fois de plus bas envoient un message qui
est contre est effectivement à la ligne
que le parti veut porter qui est celui
de la laïcité l'unicité de l'ensemble du
territoire dans lequel on considère que
les conceptions de métaphysique ceux du
domaine exclusif de la prestation
individuelle de chacun des citoyens et
donc par conséquent la fiche
effectivement doit essayer non pas de
gommer les différences en tout cas de ne
pas en faire un argument électoral et là
on voit bien que c'est un argument
électoral
donc je comprends la réaction de ce
parti et au non je dirais des valeurs de
laïcité
je verrai pas d'un meilleur oeil que
effectivement une dame est une grosse
croix lieu de ça 2 de sons de son de sa
poitrine et que monsieur à droite et une
kippa et puis aussi un drapeau du psg
parce que je préfère le psg
non mais on est dans la vraie simplicité
et donc forcément je pense
qu'effectivement en tout cas
symboliquement pour un parti comme les
rênes et je réagirai pareil en ce qui me
concerne lui dit on doit montrer que le
peuple français est un c'est une unité
de nation et que ensuite chacun en son
for intérieur chez lui là où il le veut
heureusement pratiquer la religion et la
laïcité je le rappelle elle est là pour
défendre l'ensemble des religions et
évitez simplement de prosélytisme et le
laisser aux choix individuels de chacun
donc je les comprends tout à fait en
réalité internet nous faudra ajouter
quelque chose justement je pense que ce
qui est important de rappeler ces cons
on utilise à tort et à travers et j'ai
peur d'ailleurs que ce soit un des
thèmes de la présidentielle nous terme
de laïcité
il faut rappeler comme l'a fait vincent
que la laïcité de la république c'est
une valeur du service public français
c'est à dire que dans notre constitution
est très claire là dessus
la france est une république laïque mais
tout cela ne s'applique que dans le
cadre de l'état quand l'état nous donne
un service on a rompu depuis le début du
20e siècle avec une telle qu' on est un
état catholique comme ça existe à monaco
avec des lois sur les moeurs comme le
divorce ou l'avortement qui soit teinté
religieusement par l'état c'est ça que
nous avons arrêté au début du 20e siècle
la laïcité n'est pas une question qui
anime le débat public français
en tout cas ce n'est pas ce que nous
avons voulu dans notre constitution dans
nos valeurs c'est simplement la
fourniture par l'état d'un service qui
se doit d'être neutre religieusement moi
j'ajoute que on n'a pas eu peur de
parler des démocrates chrétiens pendant
des années au début des années 50 et
même encore dans beaucoup d'autres
partis en droit comparé et on peut
penser aux allemands et c'est donc la
religion la morale l'éthique les moeurs
la politique l'économie ne sont pas des
sciences sociales où vous avez des
frontières étanches tout se mélange à ce
moment là et donc alors évidemment à mon
avis en termes de marketing comme
différent on a vraiment quelque chose
assez maladroit ici différents mais unis
cc c'est un second opus acea s'est
repris dans de l'europe et de beaucoup
d'autres fédérations comme ça mais je
crois qu'il faut rappeler que ce n'est
pas quelque chose qui est gênant de
considérer que la religion puisse faire
partie parfois du débat
la seule chose qu'il faudrait qu'on
tranche c est ce que nous avons à vie en
tant que français d'un d'un d'une
apparition de ces communautés dans le
débat public est ce qu'on a envie de se
penser comme femme comme noir comme
discriminés c'est ça la question s'est
créé cette unité du peuple français est
ce qu'il faut qu'on le fasse par la
représentation des diversités
où est ce qu'ils font on le fasse en
lego mans mais ça c'est encore quelque
chose qui relève de la question sociale
est pas du positionnement laïque qui me
semble vraiment très différent
le père voyait justement alors est ce
que oui signe d'appartenance
communautaire ou au fond représentation
de la france telle qu'elle est alors moi
je partage tout à fait l'analyse de
laurent
pour moi il ya vraiment pas la place
pour les signes ostentatoires sur les
affiches électorales
moi j'ai enfin il ya la société civile
d'un côté la société religieuse de
l'autre et je trouve que sur une affiche
électorale
on reste on reste neutre en terme de
religion
voilà c'est une position ça vous
rappelle août pardon non officiel
effectivement sur l'aspect j'allais dire
attends en 2d une seconde juste pardo
jean-charles justin charlène
effectivement se positionne toujours un
peu sur l'aspect juridique au social du
dossier moi je voudrais très très clair
je rappellerai que pas tous les
américains n'ont pas que ou pas le
monopole des pères fondateurs les pères
fondateurs de notre république
aujourd'hui les pères historique
fondateur pour moi issu est issu de la
révolution française et que je pense que
c'est bien s'il revenait parmi nous et
qui voyait une telle affiche
alors effectivement à l'époque n'aurait
pas été un voilà ça aurait été autre
chose qu'un crucifix ont été les écoles
religieux systématique et cetera issus
de l'ancien régime
il se retournerait tous genres tombe moi
je me positionne du respect
philosophique et volontairement
politique en affirmant haut et fort que
tout signe religieux n'a pas sa place
dans la sphère de l'engagement politique
au nom de tous par contre je le redis
and charlene ensuite chacun peut croire
ou de ne pas croire ça ne pose pas de
problème mais franchement à titre
personnel et je pense au sein dudit nous
ne souhaitons pas ça nous souhaitons une
république une et absolument indivisible
et là je vois je vois un signe et là je
reprends ce que vous disiez charlene qui
tombe effectivement à cette forme de
division et tout à l'heure où on le
disait je vote pas pour quelqu'un parce
qu'il est blanc noir c'est une femme
c'est un homme il est catholique il est
musulman je vote pour lui parce que je
vais considérer qu'il ou elle est la
meilleure personne pour me représenter
et pour pouvoir effectivement garantir
cette unicité c'est un peu toute la
différence qu'il peut y avoir entre
l'égalité et le fairness des américains
moi je suis pas pour le fait renaître
des américains je suis pour
effectivement cette égalité
voilà et je trouve que l'image
l'image est forte en l'occurrence pardon
je m'arrête mais les réseaux de rappeler
sur le mur je les dis c'est que c'est un
livre à l'aise en salle juste après mais
jusqu'ici on se positionne justement
dans la dans la paternité de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme je
crois que c'est vraiment une erreur sur
ce compréhension de leur philosophie
puisque le préambule de notre
déclaration des droits de l'homme est
placé sous la protection de dieu
et justement la déclaration des droits
de l'homme et la manifestation de
l'individualisme chrétiens de cette
époque là donc je crois précisément que
à cette époque la religion faisait
complètement partie du débat politique
et que c'est au contraire aujourd'hui
que nous avons besoin de cet
universalisme qui nous semblent ne plus
passer par l'identité religieuse ce que
moi je crois que faire partie du débat
social c'est à dire qu' il semble qu'une
grande partie des français n'est pas
envie de ses représentations et les
personnellement sur un plan politique
philosophique religieux
j'ai des positionnements qui peuvent
être différents mais je crois qu'en tout
cas il faut rappeler que ce n'est pas
historique où la laïcité ne fais pas
partie de ceux qui doit faire partie
d'une affiche politique ou pas ça c'est
un sentiment sociales personnelles de
conception aussi du vivre ensemble qui
est tout à fait variable d'une personne
à une autre et d'un parti ailleurs un
autre donc
rappelons juste que ça ne fait pas
partie des fonds en france et c'est une
idéologie c'est ce à quoi on a envie de
croire et certains sont choqués par
cette affiche et d'autres non voilà
c'est la seule chose que je voulais
replacer dans le dos alors je suis plus
héritiers des hussards noirs de la
république tu a raison de le dire je
l'affirmé haut ici que effectivement la
déclaration du tiers des droits de vote
soit 5 en une seconde parce que je
voudrais qu il nous reste deux minutes
et je voudrais qu'on parle du passé en
tête je crois qu'encore une fois il faut
arrêter de tourner autour du pot elle
faisait tout cela en train de faire des
figures de style faut surtout ne pas
parler de l'islam c'est à dire que anne
charlène nous parle de la démocratie
chrétienne mais quel est le rapport
un pull bear c'est totalement scandaleux
vous faites comme si se voit c'est
exactement comme une discrète man fatma
une petite étoile de david autour du cou
c'est ça on le sait bien
arrêtez de vous voiler la face c'est
juste ridicule c'est un truc de combat
ce voile sur une affiche
et chansons la france elle est comme ça
bon peur on peut là constaté non non et
si on veut que le front national face
98% sur vence est écrit chose montinari
les de la page dit qu'après ces
merveilleux et que c'est l'expression du
d'une religion comme s'il était notre
religion le valais est quelque chose
un instrument de combat arrêté mais
christine boutin christine boutin était
quand même arrivé pour discuter de la
loi sur le pacs avec une bible à
l'assemblée nationale et après il faut
replacer les choses dans leur contexte
d'inégalités science c'est une qualité
cd les cévennes tandis que le parti
démocrate-chrétien enfonce n'a pas non
plus une audience formidable alors vite
pardon il faut qu'on passe au dernier
thème parce qu'il nous reste une minute
je le passe sanitaire vous êtes pour
vous êtes contre alors les français sont
plutôt favorables à ce passe à l'it et
après il ya des critiques de tableau les
ultralibéraux qui disent comment c'est
une atteinte à la liberté pour ses fans
que passa une terre c'est plutôt une
liberté que qu'une atteinte à la liberté
on homes ou alors si on a un bon moi je
suis strictement pour bien entendu de
toute façon on pourra pas voyager si on
ne l'a pas déjà il ya beaucoup de pays
on veut pas y aller en force encore des
portes ouvertes
et puis je préférerais moi si j'étais
restaurateurs avoir des gens qui
viennent dans mon restaurant avec un
passage après ne pas avoir de clients
ensuite je fais aussi quand même un
moment donné confiance à la
confidentialité de tout ça et je vois
pas là où ils où est le crime je
rappelle que l'on injecte je crois de
force 11 vaccin aux enfants comptines s
et puis on a un carnet de santé ma fille
était avec moi ce week-end encore elle
me demandait son carnet de santé pour je
ne sais plus quoi et ça ne pose pour la
ville il ya les tests pcr ainsi on ne
veut pas être vaccinés exactement les
essais avoir le souci de l'autre une
certaine en de bout en bout
j'ai le sentiment qu'on a pas mal perdu
sur nos libertés individuelles depuis
qu'on est en train de penser à la santé
publique et je crois que c'est une bonne
chose aussi de rappeler qu'il ya des
impératifs supérieur du collectif avant
les libertés individuelles et ici le
pass sanitaire peut faire office de 2,2
ce moment où la santé des autres
essences et comptait plus que notre
liberté
sachant qu'à mon avis de toute façon
nous sommes optimistes et nous avons
besoin d'espoir aussi se passe à
lithaire sera forcément quelque chose de
provisoire lorsqu on entendra plus
parler de ce virus et que tout sera
rentré dans l'ordre
albert brio une petite réserve surtout
quand je dis les les réserves de la cnil
qui met l'accent vraiment sur le fait
provisoire qui pourrait ne pas être
provisoire etc
et c'est vrai que voilà faut rester faut
rester prudent vigile a en tout cas sur
les libertés personnelles dont charles
au départ j'étais plutôt pour maintenant
je suis plutôt contre parce que si tout
si tout avait si tout le monde est
vaccinée à quoi servira ce pass
sanitaire si ce n'est comme le dit un
père brio éventuellement et je rejoins
les razer de la cnhi ça servirait à quoi
ah ah si les gens ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner tant pis pour eux les
gens qu'ils ont qui sont vaccinées
seront vaccinés donc fondamentalement à
quoi est-ce que ce se passe sanitaire
pourrait servir la mairie on connaît
face au miroir qui durent des années on
connait le plongeur qui durent des
années
et oui moi je passe sanitaires il fait
l'objet de pas mal de fantasmes à ce
n'est pas la transmission général de
données que l'on présente souvent en
revanche je suis assez d'accord avec un
père brio et jean charles lajoie ni et
notamment sur l'avis de la cnil il faut
faire bien attention à l'accoutumance à
ce genre de procédés faire en sorte que
ça soit bien temporaire vous savez les
libertés on se moque de les perdre tant
que c'est progressif et il faudra être
bien vigilant là dessus
merci infiniment merci à bercy fait les
moines père brio et le rang mazaury et à
très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
boeuf
[Musique]